[Music]
award show season is hitting high gear
the final countdown is on to the Golden
Globes on Sunday indeed and what's so
great about the globe's is it brings
together the biggest stars from film and
television it's fun party and we are
breaking down what you can expect Meryl
Streep Emma Stone the Ryans it's tough
predicting the globe's but ETR lines
danny director was all-in he studied the
nominees and says there's one race you
can't ignore the race for Best Actor in
a Musical or Comedy is the one to watch
it is the Battle of the Ryans Gosling
versus Reynolds Gosling is nominated for
his role in la-la-land
Reynolds for Deadpool I'm gonna make a
bold prediction here and say Ryan
Reynolds comes out on top Deadpool had a
wide release and a lot of eyes were on
it not to mention the viral marketing
campaign and the fact that Reynolds
himself has been pounding pavement at
various screenings and Q&A and I think
that really gives him the edge here
still la-la-land is the globe's front
runner with 7 nominations including one
for star Emma Stone for Best Actress
Musical or Comedy Emma Stone is
absolutely irresistible in la-la-land
she's racked up so much attention for
this role and rightfully so but of
course she's up against Meryl Streep
Meryl is a Golden Globes darling having
won eight and it really poses a threat
to Emma in my opinion this race is a
toss-up I'm just taking it one day at a
time
Natalie Portman is a clear front-runner
to win Best Actress in a Drama and
Jackie the entire film is hers and she
chews up every scene she's given check
let me check the frontrunner for Best
Drama R between two indie darlings
moonlight and Manchester by the seat now
I've seen both and both of these films
made me cry but I think in this case
Manchester has the edge one factor
producer Matt Damon the Golden Globes
winner has been personally promoting the
film I'll be able to say to my kids when
they're older
you know when I had any bit of leverage
in this town I helped to get this made
you